what about the opposite stance of women
who are feminists who think then you
have to be more like men again we kind
of touched on it briefly in our last
question but that you almost have to
suppress your beauty and feminine
femininity to be acceptable right I
think that there is a belief or a train
of thought that you are disempowering
women and discrediting their
intellectual capabilities that would be
on the same level as men if you allow
them to value or exploit the advantages
that they have in terms of physical
beauty and aesthetics so I think I
always felt that way - growing up like I
didn't want to be a cheerleader I wanted
to play basketball and play the sport
and I was like you know they're not
really doing anything after I got older
and I was in more than one situation I
really switched professional situations
to try to get a more level playing field
so I'm very ambitious and you know I
wanted to do 100% of anything and that I
did I started to realize like actually
level playing fields maybe really aren't
there like they were when when we as
little girls were growing up and we were
in high school or they put the boys and
you know elementary school or college or
all in the same classrooms and different
dynamics enter into the workplace as you
get older so I started to think and I
don't know if other feminists will think
about this or
give it some consideration maybe we
should be exploiting the advantages that
we have and not necessarily look at
looking at them as disempowering you
know the the qualities that women have
that are comparable to men and don't
have to do with physical appearance and
aesthetics and then there's the whole
issue of you know why our aesthetics
important to society and gender why does
sex sell you know why do they put women
on the cover of women's magazines and
men's magazines you know there are no
right and wrong answers but it's
certainly worth a conversation and we do
know that we have a problem to fix if
you know we look at the statistics so
you